[Music]
Josh so great to be here with you today
thank you for having me of course so
let's start by telling me what does your
company do slate we sell high protein
chocolate milks and lattes oo delicious
yes of course taste is number one
priority and we say we sell strength so
the high protein gives people strength
and we create products that are not only
better for people but better for the
planets we have an environmental Mission
too very cool I'll dive into
sustainability later but I first want to
hear about your founding story sure so
my co-founder Manny luin and I are both
from the Greater Boston area and we grew
up playing a ton of sports whether it
was basketball football baseball I
played golf Manny says it doesn't count
as a sport but still count it and uh our
moms would always give us chocolate milk
after we after games after practice and
it was always great protein good
electrolytes I didn't realize that uh
chocolate milk actually has more
electrolytes than most sports drinks
just naturally so we drank it all the
time we got older became lactose
intolerant so we couldn't drink it
anymore and had to start drinking these
name brands that basically screamed to
the world that we were the guys with
tummy issues so we yes I use the word
tummy a lot in this job uh and we wanted
to just create chocolate milk that we
could actually drink every day and feel
comfortable with after having to drink
these products for so long um and before
that we actually started testing out
some different protein powders and
protein shakes and things that were very
intense branded and that were typically
full of artificial sweeteners and just
didn't make us feel very good and so we
went back to drinking lactose free
chocolate milk and uh again with those
kind of brutal names and so that was
where kind of slate was born we just
wanted to create a chocolate milk for us
we could drink every day and by doing
that and creating a high protein version
of it we also figured that lattes used
milk as a base and so let's create our
favorite coffee drinks as better for you
as well now part of the things I love
about your story is that you guys went
on Shark Tank we did tell me about how
that experience is for you besides the
55 page NDA that I can't say a lot of
the things that happened no it was uh it
was honestly an incredible experience as
an r preneur no matter what happens on
that stage it was one of the coolest
things I've ever done being out in LA
and doing it meeting everybody and for
us it was we did a Kickstarter video um
so we got a bunch of pre-orders some
people and our video which Manny was the
the center of attention on he is the
better actor in the group uh what was
apparently very funny I thought it was
and the casting team reached out to us
and so when we went out there on the
show we had no final product they were
labade samples we had no sales all we
had was the kickstarter and so we
definitely were a little bit early
before for uh wanting to kind of be
ready to go out there but we were like
you know what this is an opportunity to
get in front of people potentially find
a great partner for the business and uh
we we got destroyed on national
television it was definitely brutal on
our egos as we say great for the brand
tough on the ego and it aired about a
year later and when we look at it now
they run it every two months like it's
on all the time which again great
recognition people still tell us but and
my mom is still pretty upset that uh
she's like you gotta let them know how
good you guys are doing now and I'm like
well maybe if they read Forbes they'll
find out there you go exactly so what
made you think then that you could take
this leap into entrepreneurship and have
a successful business a lot of people
talk about it they're like oh it's
amazing that you guys were able to do
this and I first of all my family has
been incredibly supportive uh when I
first before this actually work for a
real estate tech company and I remember
when I was leaving to start the world of
chocolate milk my dad was like how many
people wealthy people do you know in
real estate I was like a lot he's like
how many people wealthy people do you
know in Tech and I was like a lot and
he's like how many wealthy people do you
know in milk and I was like Dad that's
the opportunity that's not the so that
was kind of that big jump but for me you
know I'm from Greater Boston area we
were going to start the business in
Boston I just graduated college when we
first started this thing and so you know
I had saved some money from working
during college at the tech company and I
knew that worst case scenario if I fell
on my face I my parents were there to to
catch me could move in with them I don't
know if they would like that or not but
very very lucky to have that support
system behind me and Manny my business
business partner similarly um and I tell
everybody too that going into something
alone is very very hard if Manny and I
didn't have each other I don't think I
would have even gotten off the ground
and so being able to lean on each other
during all the hard times from
conception of the idea to actually
launching our first product was two full
years and so two years of being in our
heads against the wall again I don't
know if if I was alone I would able to
kind of like push through and do it so
um very very lucky in a lot of ways but
I just I love it it wouldn't do anything
different it's a really tough spot right
now for for cpg Consumer package Goods
Brands and you mentioned you that
there's a lot of incumbents in your
space how do you stand out from both you
know the other startups out there doing
milk doing lattes doing RTD stuff and
then stand out also from the incumbents
and the players who have been around for
years yeah so for us it was a key of not
only differentiating the product itself
but the brand too and so for us when we
looked at the world of protein and and
milk specifically is how we started as
better for you chocolate milk and we've
kind of morphed into this strength brand
we so high protein products um at first
it was there's little kid drinks that
are bright colors and animals on the
front and then there was like muscle M
like really intense protein shakes and
we're like we need for men right and so
we talk about it the evolution of
protein as a nutrient is very similar to
the evolution of Fitness where 20 25
years ago Fitness was Arnold
swartzenegger Mal's bodybuilding and you
fast forward to now like yoga and
pelaton and it's so much more inclusive
to all genders to people of all ages all
demographics and so we think that
protein is such a great nutrient that
people need for their daily lives not
just for working out but just it keeps
you full for longer so when you snack if
you have something that's higher in
protein it's better so we just want to
incorporate protein in people's diets
more often um and so so anyway so from a
brand perspective we wanted to make sure
it's something very approachable that
everybody could have we took a lot of
inspiration from one of our investors
Peter Ray Hall from our xar very simple
you tell people what it is and then they
can use it for a variety of reasons you
don't need a muscly guy in the front to
say that it can be used to build muscle
so that was the brand part and then from
a product part we want to make sure we
had a could build a moat around it it's
very easy in the world of consumer goods
typically to copy somebody if you're
making every consumer product is very
hard to get off the ground I'm not
tanking away from it but you can make a
bar or granola in your kitchen with
ingredients you find at Whole Foods if
you're using a milk base or Ultra
filtered milk which is a special type of
milk that we use that's higher in
protein and less in Sugar um you need to
do that typically with like a lab Manny
and I tried we bought some stuff from
the grocery store it did not go well so
it's big machinery Crees big equipment
and so the these different pieces of
technology that we use to make sure our
product is 20 g of protein without sugar
and shelf stable are that supply chain
had not previously been put together and
it's very the minimums are so high it's
very hard for just anyone to do it so we
have a great moat around the the smaller
companies larger companies we think this
brand resonates differently than kind of
how they're approaching it and kind of
carving our niche in there yeah that
makes sense now talk to me about your
fundraising Journey fundraising uh
always always always fundraising I feel
like in this world uh there's a couple
different approaches we've seen you know
big rounds every once in a while for us
we've kind of raised as we needed it and
so very early on uh Mandy and I put in
our own money and then we had an angel
investor give us a $15,000 check just to
get our initial branding and formulation
done um we wasted a lot of our money on
a bunch of stupid things early on as
well but um kind of along the way I've
had some awesome people on the team and
our goal was um to date we've raised
about $25 million and our goal
throughout the whole way was get people
on the team that are smarter than us get
people that have done it before and so
Peter Ray Hall from rxbar who's the
founder there co-founder was one of our
investors um Doug Bouton co-founder of
Halo tops and investor we have Amanda
and Drew who the co-founders of yaso
frozen Greek yogurt so just try to get
people in the exact same space or
adjacent spaces that can then help us
along the way and then we've had other
family offices that have been involved
in cpg as well and in the Sports World
so again just get that Community around
us and some people knock the idea of
having a long cap table sometimes it's
harder to manage but for us it's just
more brand and ambassadors that are out
there talking about the brand very cool
now where can we find Slate and how many
customers do you have so right now we
are in probably about 12,000 stores
across the country you can find it at
places like Walmart and Whole Foods and
Wegman's and Publix and um a bunch of
others uh we are launching some new ones
in the new year so our store count
should potentially almost double coming
into next year uh plus we sell online
nationally through our website slate.com
and then amazon.com
and uh we're very excited to keep
growing the business very cool what
would you say is the most challenging
part of running your
company so many things all the time
finding really good people is really
hard and uh for us early on before we
made our first hire we didn't know we
needed it until we met Anna car at a
coffee shop she was looking um one of my
friends introduced me to her and was
like oh she's looking for a job in food
she just graduated with her Masters in
nutrition I'm like I don't know what I
can do to help but sure I don't even
have company yet and I met her in two
minutes in the conversation I was like
we got to find a way to get her involved
so it took us almost 6 months to
actually pay her uh but Anna now runs
all of our national Partnerships so she
runs the partnership with the UFC she
runs all of our influencer relationships
she runs everything for us and so that
was kind of our model of at her core
she's an entrepreneur and we always need
to hire entrepreneurs because
everybody's too busy to just just be a
manager just to be good at one thing if
we can have a Swiss army knife team of
now over 40 people it's going to make us
go a long way so finding those people is
very challenging but it's definitely
reaps the rewards when it comes what
would it take for you to sell your
company and is that your
goal I don't know Mandy and I talk about
it sometimes I think when you do raise
money you have to have an Exit Plan and
so for us in the world of consumer
especially uh food and beverage food and
beverage there's not that many public
companies and do I want to be running a
public company I don't know uh but so I
think that the most logical path for
slate is a potential acquisition
position down the road that's what most
I think consumer food and beverage
companies do when they are do hit a
certain number just because there's
certain levels of distribution that are
just so high and um that we're never
going to be able to achieve on our own
without a strategic partner but having
said that there's some great examples
like Chobani out there that have taken
Dairy and really gone wide what excites
Manny and I so much is with the platform
of protein and especially Ultra filtered
milk basically high protein lactose free
better for the world as our base if we
were a different company you might be
more limited to your category for us
we're hyper focused on drinks we have
high protein milkshakes or chocolate
milks and we have high protein coffees
or lattes but our platform could go into
basically anything that you think of
right now that Quest has done in the
world of food or that fair life is doing
in the World of Beverage and I think
that there's a wide area we could
potentially grow this business for the
next 30 40 50 years it just kind of
depends on what the opportunities are in
front of us you talked about
sustainability earlier so I want to
Circle back on that how is that such a
big part of your brand it's it's really
important to us I mean I think for us
it's uh not only important to us to have
making humans better but we got to take
care of the planet that we're on and so
we wanted to figure out a truly
authentic way I think sometimes
companies get a little bit too involved
in the world of they need to do
something because they think they have
to or have some sort of ESG goal they
need to hit and so for us they starting
with the aluminum can so we're 100%
recyclable aluminum can where a lot of
things are in plastic bottles you can
see it in the ocean we learned a lot
about how a lot of the waste that
doesn't end up getting recycled in North
America ends up in the Indian Ocean so
we actually partnered with um a group to
be a plastic neutral certified business
and have plastic neutral certified
products because it's really hard not to
use any plastic in business and so we
wrap our shrink or we shrink wrap our
cases our pallets marketing materials
things like that and so what we've done
is partner with this group to employ
people actually in both Africa and
Indonesia to pull a pound of plastic out
of the ocean for every pound of plastic
we put into the world um and so for us
that was really important to have that
sustainability Mission and really help
clean up that that side of the world
because it is a lot of what's coming
from North America um and on the other
side of that throughout our entire
supply chain find ways to continue to
make things better so we do come from
dairy we are from cows so we have um uh
cows that we using the milk that again
we make lactose free but we have methane
machines on the farms to help convert
that into energy to power the farm so
it's not just wasted methane or hurting
the environment when you Ultra filter
milk the way I describe it is you put
milk through a br filter and the BR
filter catches the big lactose sugars
and some of the waters and filters them
out so it flows through is a condensed
form of milk that's higher in protein
without the sugar so we think it's kind
of like a hack in the milk of the future
um but it has less percentage of water
so the water that gets filtered out
actually goes back onto our Farms so the
Farms are using less outside water some
of our Farms are completely water
neutral actually um they're just pulling
it out of the milk and using back on the
farm so anywhere that we can kind of
bring that in we want to very cool is
there one businessle rule that you
always operate by no matter
what uh we talk a lot about uh trust and
respect that is kind of like the two
that kind of one pillar at slate where
um we talk about it it's almost like as
your spouse it's you need to have that
constant level of communication that
constant level of trust and respect for
everybody on your team whether it's
somebody that's your partner a vendor a
client those things cannot be broken if
either of those things are broken and
kind of communication that fuels both of
those things it just things won't work
yeah it's too hard to be successful as a
small business going up against Coke
Pepsi and these massive massive beverage
and food companies that if you can't
even rely on the people around you and
just be a good human being you're never
going to make it now what's next for you
talk to me about any exciting things you
have in 2024 in the pipeline or what's
exciting you right now yeah so we just
launched the partnership with UFC which
was very exciting so Dana White who
helped start the organization or they
actually bought it 200 2 was the
president for a long time now CEO found
out about slate uh from a friend of his
and actually started drinking it every
day he was on a health Journey himself
he ended up losing 30 pounds by eating
cleaner and slate was kind of his go-to
protein and for us that kind of future
goal of being that associated with
Fitness and sports kind of the way
Gatorade is for hydration we think slate
can be the protein side of that because
we think that Sports overall are kind of
lacking that world of protein and so the
UFC as the fastest growing sport in the
country in America for us was a great
place to be of like that Insurgent like
you have like the the main four Sports
which is the kind of credible Coke and
Pepsi companies then you have UFC and
slate kind of building together almost
they're obviously much bigger so very
excited to see that we launched that a
couple months ago but we really haven't
leaned into the power of both Dana and
UFC and really bringing protein to the
the Forefront there and as we continue
to expand with more of our national
retailers having that marketing be
pushed behind it with not only them but
a lot of other athletes and other
influencers kind of all over the board
I'm very excited to see actually putting
together like Mass marketing with
distribution to see what we can really
do very cool and one last question for
you Josh what would you like your legacy
to
be I will definitely when you talked
about selling the business I think one
of the things what's hard is when you
sell the business sometimes they go away
or they change it and so I for me I
still want to be 60 70 years from now
walking down the street and seeing
people drinking slate and having their
kids drinking slate uh for me it's
making the world and leaving the world a
little bit better than I left it so
personally I've always been really into
health and fitness and somebody like my
dad and my my parents actually both you
know we've all tried to be as healthy as
we can and my dad has a nasty Sweet
Tooth he loves his chocolate chip
cookies and anything sweet and so for me
being able to now give him a product
that tastes really good to him that's
sweet but also is not sacrificing his
nutrition if we can keep coming out with
more and more products like that for
even just him help him live a little bit
longer be a little bit happier and
healthier if we can do that for more
people people that's really the goal so
just leave a little bit of an impact as
best we can awesome well thank you so
much Josh I appreciate for having me of
[Music]
course